have an opportunity to talk with the
chief of staff for the vice president
and this is the subject stocks remaining
volatile today after the Dow Jones fell
sharply again yesterday rallying just a
bit today closing below 20,000 yesterday
for the first time in three years nearly
wiping out all of the gains of president
Trump's presidency shares of companies
that are America's backbone Mike Hilton
Ford American Airlines have been in
freefall in recent days as you know
although Hilton at least is back up
today Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell spoke about phase three of a
stimulus package earlier watch this is a
form of emergency tax relief that we
want to push taxpayers right away it's
not an ordinary policy but this is no
ordinary time the American people need
help and they need it fast this will
deliver it
mark short is chief of staff for vice
president pence so glad for your time
today let me jump right in what is
coming in terms of what's already passed
in the space three four Americans and
stimulus
well Harris thanks for having me I think
that what's most important is is
immediate relief to finance relief to
American people because we believe that
if you look at what's happened in China
you look at what's happened in South
Korea these outbreaks have about an
eight to ten week life span where its
most intense we've actually seen data in
South Korea that's even a little more
encouraging than that so if we're able
to get the American people to to abide
by the guidance that the administration
has put forward we think we can shrink
the duration of the outbreak and also
lower the severity of it and so we're
really trying to focus on those people
who are most impacted by losing hourly
wages losing their their short-term jobs
and so we do think that in some cases
that is actually tax relief and it's
also making sure that small community
banks have liquidity that they need so
that for those small family-owned
businesses that need cash to continue
payrolls they're able to get that from
those banks so that's really a focus is
making sure that the small community
banks are liquidated because we think
that the the big banks are in good shape
right now so we'll
people get checks I think that that will
be a part of one of the the measures I
think that you know when you come
together on anything like this there's
there's gonna be a bipartisan element
that brings up multiple different ideas
together and it seems that that is that
is one that has a lot of support in
Capitol Hill mark is this moving past
enough I think actually what you're
seeing is significant cooperation among
Republicans and Democrats were
encouraged with the pace that it's
moving
and we're also Aris and really
encouraged by the cooperation we're
seeing from the American people it's not
just individuals that are that are that
are practicing the social distancing but
businesses that are encouraging it as
well as churches and faith communities
and so we think the spirit of America
coming together in this moment to help
defeat the virus at this time is an
encouraging sign and we do think that
there that actually Congress is working
at a rapid pace as well all right I'm
sure boaters will continue to put
pressure on Congress if they think it's
not moving fast enough you and I shown
each other for a while so I know that
this is right down your alley we're
gonna try something new here we're gonna
give you one of our viewer questions you
ready this is Erica T from rural a rural
area and she has this question let's
watch my town of a little over five
thousand still sees travelers coming
through using gas stations restaurants
and hotels we have one small hospital
with 25 beds and one respirator and
several outlying towns with no such
facilities the closest major hospital is
over an hour away my question is what
contingency plan does the government
have to support rural areas mark well
this is a tough one
no it's a great question by Erika I
think that what the government the
federal government does is it develops
plans that they cooperate with all
states and so really state and local
governments have their own plans in
dealing with these sorts of pandemics
it's why we provide the guidelines for
the states to implement but I do want
Erica to be encouraged I think you heard
some of the data today in which there
are three states that have more than 50%
of the cases and there's really ten
counties across the United States have
one in 50% of the cases across the whole
country we don't want to see that spread
which is why we've pushed forward those
guidelines to make sure we can contain
as best possible but but we do in
typically the resources that are
provided the president has by declaring
a national emergency set up FEMA to have
emergency operations that are active in
all ten regions of the country so
governor's can work with those
individual regional administrators to
make sure that the hospitals and those
have the equipment that they need yeah
that's important I know the defense
production act to the president was
talking about when he might trigger some
things when you hear that one breathing
apparatus for people and duress that
they only have one that no matter what
configuration you have is disturbing
I'll give you a quick last word
well actually we we actually have a lot
of ventilators that that are being
distributed across the country but even
more for these are the respirator masks
there's it husband I think a lot of
break this here because the legislation
was pushed with this administration's
help provide its no liability protection
so the construction mask that typically
producers like 3m are reluctant to sell
the hospitals because of fear of
lawsuits we've actually made that easier
so they've already been produced and
they're now getting distributed to
hospitals across the country that is
good information mark short the chief of
staff for our VP appreciate your time
thank you sir